they help so well on defense they make
you shoot the ball from the perimeter
you have to be able to knock down shots
and of course get the ball inside ha ha
to Zion that's the power game the big
fella little bit large pretty impressive
after crashing to the floor hitting two
free throws getting onto it is what
happens when you can shoot from deep
Zion now we'll try the three delivers
outlaw look at around say that'll like
this guy inside or out the six points in
a forty second span back down the black
share on the blocks the Sun rejects it
how about that down the for over
fourteen warmest out of position and was
holding on design once he got beat
Wilkins really made that play ties it at
thirty in one moves right then come back
down nice find by bear with that size
able to get free off the screen had a
good look at it they're not hitting her
shots
hold on side and took his back in front
by walk six the largest lead of the game
at Virginia Tech at his Jones
[Applause]
how can you go put this I thought that
was going out of bounds he's tied his
career as this mark with the tennis s
this is a really like go steal a fight
forcing them to double if that's what
you want to do he split it and even
closed it for the hands of Blackshear
marvelous play
[Applause]
the other end oh yes
down the two Blackshear with three fouls
on side track past everybody they just
can't play with the fouls much less the
lack of foot speed to cover jokes about
it but this I think they'll take instead
he felt right